des toits effondrés des murs éventrés
voilà tout ce qu'il reste des maisons de
ses habitants de nikopol la nuit
précédente ils ont été bombardés à trois
reprises par les russes leur ville et à
seulement dix kilomètres de la centrale
nucléaire de zappos ridja alors certains
craignent une catastrophe encore plus
grave
nous mourrons tous c'est une catastrophe
nucléaire se produit
pas seulement nous ici en ukraine mais
le monde entier c'est très grave
mon mari a chuté cet appartement parce
qu'il voulait laisser quelque chose à
ses enfants il est mort il n'a rien
laissé à ses enfants
la centrale de zappos ridge à la plus
grande d'europe est occupé depuis mars
par l'armée russe
mais ce sont toujours des techniciens
ukrainien qui la font fonctionner situé
près de la ligne de front les environs
de la centrale ont été plusieurs fois
bombardée ces dernières semaines moscou
et kiev se renvoient la responsabilité
de ces attaques de quoi susciter
l'inquiétude face au risque d'une
catastrophe nucléaire les nations unies
ont exhorté la russie et l'ukraine à
fournir un accès sécurisé et immédiat
aux inspecteurs de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique
un accord est nécessaire de toute
urgence pour établir sa porridge et en
tant qu'infrastructure purement civil et
pour assurer la sécurité de la zone
nous devons être clairs sur le fait que
tous dommages potentiels à la centrale
ou à tout autre installation nucléaire
en ukraine conduisant à un éventuel
accident nucléaire aurait des
conséquences catastrophiques non
seulement pour le voisinage immédiat
mais pour la région et au delà
pour l'heure la mission de l'ail et anna
toujours pas pu être programmés en
parallèle moscou discute avec paris de
la possibilité d'une visite par des
inspecteurs indépendants